okay okay i think that as you're
progressing to be as you're progressing
to be a better human being i find that
your brother is regressing
they tell you about what happened over
the weekend no i would like to know no
what is you're gonna say what happened
this does anyone know what happened over
the weekend
okay what are you going to say before we
even get up guy might stop you the
biggest thing all right well i'm
stopping you
what that does has no
business in in this podcast anymore i
feel like it's my right to tell this
story it's my story to tell guess why
what you guys cuz i didn't [ __ ] put
your poop in a doggy bag didn't i whoa
it's my story now as us
if i have to do the cleanup it's my
story to tell
i have to know the story now please tell
me
tell us bobby please tell your story you
tell them
so i get a phone call i get a phone call
he's coming home from from warner
brothers and i got a frantic phone call
he's like
that's not something so bad just what
happened
oh yeah he went to terry
which is great food by the way
no there's a new one on instagram
and i get a phone call and he's like
babe something really bad just happened
in my head the first thing i was like oh
my god he's finally run over somebody
and like that's what i mean because of
his driving yeah cause he's a wild
driver
dude his driving's insane yeah so then i
was like [ __ ] what happened
and he's like i need help i'm downstairs
in the garage and there's poo everywhere
[Music]
and i'm like how is there poo everywhere
it turns out that he was on the freeway
on route to come home
stuck in traffic
couldn't make it out of the exit pulled
over into the side of the freeway
climbed over into the back seat
and took [ __ ] in the back seat
do you like dad
that's something dad
you just looked dead
i can't believe it you're just like dad
man that's
exactly what dad would do let me tell
you this story all the time
my dad was driving he used to drive this
van
because he put uh his merchandise in it
and then he was on some kind of
freelancer highway
and he couldn't stop either but he did
it on a paper plate at least
he did it right on the scene
disgusting man and then he comes he
comes running upstairs
you're a goddamn animal man
you need help bro
and can i tell you what happened he's a
afterwards he's a beast
so he tells
oh he he comes up and i see his butt as
he runs into the bathroom and it's just
diarrhea all over his pants
so then i'm thinking he couldn't even
take his [ __ ] pants off it's just his
[ __ ] it's his health
no we need to talk seriously
[Music]
and then
i said okay fine i'll take it to the car
wash in the morning but i was like you
know what i'm not going to do it i'm
going to have jenna do it
because you know jenna needs the money
and i so i told her you better give her
500
she came in in a hazmat suit she came i
swear to god she came in fully suited up
but then he
it was 50.
oh lord and then he said
he said i tried to
i tried to clean it with a spray as best
as i could so jenna should be fine dry
so jenna basically
had
but then that's not the worst part on
the way there
on the way there jenna checked the back
seat
because she was like something smells
really bad are you sure that he cleaned
it with spray
and she goes back there and there's two
big turds that kind of just roll have
been rolling around in the back seat i
was camouflaged into this yeah
so she then has to
she then has she calls me she's like oh
my god i don't know what to do but
there's still poo rolling around back
there
and so i she had to pick it up she had
to use her hand she had to my point is
now see what that's
racist
how many dicks do you think bobby has
sucked in his lifetime
on purpose
yes of course on purpose
oh he doesn't know he doesn't know
anything about that kind of stuff
oh
i thought you guys are i'm saying
stop laughing
he doesn't happen not everyone knows
that i do things like i used to do
things like that yeah so
don't forget but let me just say the
picture the the picture
the picture that you painted about your
friendship of this long decade-long
friendship and seeing hookers together i
would assume that you would divulge that
type of information to someone like him
no because i don't tell like him people
some certain people like sebastian
i can't look at sebastian
yeah i'm closer with sebastian too i
went to his [ __ ] wedding right but i
can't look at sebastian monoskanko
because i know how he is he paints his
nails
right he's cleanly he's like a real
cosmopolitan guy yeah well he's that's a
weird example though i mean we can't
have regular friends you and i can't
have regulars yeah yeah we just can't
but i can't look at sebastian and go hey
i used to suck i sucked a couple of
dicks in my life a couple
when he was younger when i was younger i
was a kid teenager but but a couple
the first time is like okay you're
experimenting you're at boy scout camp i
get it
but the second one
[Laughter]
all with white boys
i get it though asian guy and girl
they're the same from behind
i have this weird porn obsession of
course of older men and younger women
okay
not just any older man i'm talking about
90 year old decrepit like on the verge
of death okay that's super super gross
and kind of a bummer yeah
but this is this is the slippery slope
you go down with pornography right right
yeah i talked about this once where it's
like hey uh you know i thought that like
fetish used to mean like fishnet
pantyhose right that's fetish not at all
not at all no it's just people pooping
into hats
and then someone has to wear that
and then that's the whole thing yeah
yeah
the the the suggestions that come up on
websites are weird yeah but
your thing really really bugs me a lot
why why does it bother you so it's guys
who look like stan lee yeah
oh yeah is stanley in any of them and
the other are like so standard
from
fresh
professional okay
what you're talking about is
crimes
i mean it's fine i'm totally curious but
these are incredible i know you're
camping yeah of course what it is here's
what it is and i'm gonna just say lisa
everyone listens whether you're blushing
so i'm gonna explain to everyone right
now listening okay okay yeah i don't
want people to let get out of control
but it is i'm not into
when when i see the old men i see me
because i feel like i'm old and i feel
like i'm not sexy and so when i see
you know i mean older dude i don't think
this got better than what you would
describe
it actually
it was one of these horrible things
where it was kind of vague and then it
got more specific and it actually got
weighted
yeah so you're saying there's no proper
asian representation in american porn
see that's another thing it's like
there's have you ever seen
an american porn and seen some asian
dude you know no you're right yeah i'm
not cause i always have to chuck noodle
you know chuck noodle chuck noodles not
in it
classic porn star yeah
frank dumpling is not in it
if frank dumpling was rolling up to
somebody it's a fat chinese guy yeah
with just some regular girl that i would
i would download and that would be
support like crazy rich asians yeah like
asakira right it's always she's always
with
some dude that looks like
you know
yeah josh brolin
i got a real question for you bobby
it feels like you're really focusing on
the dudes a lot
now i mean i don't want i'm not i don't
want it to peel his onion like a tongue
but i'm like well she's fine but why
doesn't this guy look like stan lee
why is this guy not a korean stan lee
who's about to die
with an oxygen tube otherwise
so yeah you're right you know what i
feel like i need i mean why why does it
matter i need i it it does it doesn't
matter because if there's a penis in the
scene right yeah and people are doing
things to the penis right
i can't ignore the fact that there is
penile in it and so you know it's like
um you put yourself
in that man's you know he's basically
playing yourself
okay
you know keep talking yeah it's not like
i want to suck it
okay right it's more like that's me
no i understand it's it's wish
fulfillment right yeah but no it's not
so you don't go to pov stuff because you
got to see the weird old gentleman yeah
i hate pov yeah i can't do pov you like
people
why why why that face george yeah it's
better than seeing like good old face no
but i don't i don't like the angles of
it yeah right
it's like you know i saw one p over what
you just see a girl's belly button in
her mouth
you can't see the whole you can't see
the whole stan lee
yeah
he did something so embarrassing last
week
so bobby was um flew to atlanta last
week oh i know this what he started
bragging about oh me and steve aoki are
friends now and we like we've been
texting blah blah blah
they ran into each other at the airport
yeah and what happened at the airport or
outside the hotel the hotel i'm sorry
could i tell the story
and so he i mean like the whole his
whole message to me like one after the
other like yeah so like daddy's got his
digits like i said bragging to me
because you're you you're a huge steve
aoki fan no i'm not oh no well i went to
like one of his shows and i was in
barcelona but then i was like yeah i saw
she's a fan so i said i said to him oh i
i saw him once when i was in barcelona
right and so he texted me back he's like
oh yeah but like do you have his digits
are you going to breakfast with him
tomorrow i'm like come on [ __ ]
like i'm not trying to yeah he's trying
to like brag about this brand new
friendship he created right
and so i guess him he screenshotted a a
conversation between him and steve aoki
he says it says hey dude so glad i ran
into you and bobby goes hey man glad
we're friends he screenshotted that with
the intent to send it to me to show it
show to me as proof that they're now
friends right instead he sent that
screenshot back to steve iowa back to
stephen
follow question that's ridiculous how
did you what did you do did you like it
no buy or what well i try to as i send
it i realized i did it and i try to like
click back onto the thing right you
could delete it see if we can delete it
like somehow like not how to capture it
between that and the cloud
bobby tries to beat the club yeah but
did it was already sent so then i
started kind of sweating in my face oh
damn and then i just went ha ha ha ha
i have i don't know where my phone is
about because i meant to say i go ha ha
and i told him the truth i meant to send
that to my girlfriend i sent it to you
how embarrassing and he said and he goes
that's cool dude and he kind of laughed
it off
but then it never i think we're done in
our relationship i think he's thinking
like oh my god
oh what you don't know i play ice hockey
we've never talked about this all the
time can i tell you something he is an
amazing ice like a figure skater we've
never talked about this he is elegant
when did you play listen everyone listen
to right now okay papa right the slept
king right he's a king correct yeah
kings know things all right and i have
physical attributes that people don't
even [ __ ] know it yes i'm shaped like
a dumpling
yes i'm round all right and fat right
but papa can ice skate
papa can play tennis he can play ping
pong and he also can play um he can
wrestle can i also tell you guys
something please look in the closet he
has his own pair of skates yeah i've got
hockey skates powers how would you do
that for play since that was five whoa
yeah i play ice hockey i could skate
backwards i know how to play i know the
rules we went to um
adam sandler's christmas party at the
pickwick about four years ago and bobby
brought his own skates because he
thought that
in his head that if he was impressive on
the ice that he could be friends with
were you gonna just skate at a party
well i didn't
think right
number one okay
it's not as if i don't like if you asked
adam sandler who's bobby lee he wouldn't
know who i am of course i've just had
like limited discussions with him and
yes i thought that if i was like jazzing
it up on the ice right
but i didn't realize
i didn't realize that 10 000 people go
to his christmas party oh it's not like
a small no when they asked me they're
like you want to go to adam's house
there's going to be like 50 people there
i'm going to make it yeah i'm going to
make it yeah i'll bring my own
[ __ ] drive to like thousand oaks to
get his [ __ ] skate sharpened yeah
yeah yeah yeah and he was the only guy
who brought his own skates yeah yeah and
i did backward skating
and we didn't run into him once at the
party he did an eagle party no he had
his band played yeah so they were in
this one place where everyone was
and then we were just at the ice skating
rink but it was still a fun [ __ ]
party it was how fun was that so fun um
i do want to talk about um something
that happened over the weekend bobby
came home from set after having a 12
hour work night
and he immediately came through the door
talked to my sister and started throwing
his underwear through his jeans in the
wash all right
um so explain to us what happened wait
wait say that again okay
put it in a plastic wallet
oh my god
it's
i swear to god i didn't want to talk
about this but
okay
okay
okay so i was shooting this movie
okay well before i went okay i had at
seven o'clock
p.m call time saturday night
so i drove to sherman oaks or no
woodland hills that's where it is okay
and i'm driving to the i see a game stop
i'm gonna get a new controller right now
and head seat pp's so i went in there a
pod they gave me a gigantic bag
i put in the car
then the you know i parked where the
parking lot is they drive me to the set
i [ __ ] worked 12 [ __ ] hours it was
brutal was it a movie it was a movie
and at like five in the morning we did
hit second lunch which is like
they have to do it sag union-wise
and then they go we got this this meat
like where is it from we don't know some
place
i'm like five in the morning
where did you get meat like it was like
chicken skewers
chicken or beef
chicken egg beef but i ate the chicken
but five a.m yeah chicken in the morning
maybe it was hello guys
it wasn't halal okay it was not that
good it wasn't good it was under cooked
man
it was underground i don't know what
happened but i'm tired and then
at like six in the morning i'm at my
last shot like 6 30
and i just started farting a lot
you know i mean and then even
in the scenes yeah in the scenes and the
cameraman goes even one time goes what's
that smell
and i didn't say anything
i didn't say anything because in my head
i'm like [ __ ] if i could if i could just
pure [ __ ] just get in my car drive home
right
so then
i wrap i don't fill up my paperwork
which i still have to do sometimes yeah
and i get i have the van drive into my
car i'm in the car it's now sunday
morning i'm on the 101 speeding and all
of a sudden in my head i go
i'm not going to make it
i'm not gonna make it to a restaurant
yeah i'm not gonna make it home not at
home right anywhere oh the [ __ ] was
building up no it was out
it was probably out it was wet yeah like
my underwear was already brown a little
bit
it was peeking
in so i pull over
and i go to a gas station
i park into this gas station it's closed
the gas station right i go to the back
seat i pull my pants down and i throw
the two boxes you don't mean that's
controllers
yeah yeah and i'm not even kidding you
it was filled with juice
it was a solid juice i mean was it solid
or juicy it was all juice it was pure
diarrhea yeah yeah juice
i threw the bag
the gas station that sees the gamestop
bag i'm sorry if you hear this
but i threw it right
collide pull my pants back up and now my
underwear is cold [ __ ]
cold poo yeah yeah oh that's the worst
so i sit on my seat and it's and it's
cold poo it's just pure just shitty yeah
yeah it's not it's pure it's all poop
okay
pure yes
wash his i don't come home right and i
um i take my underwear off no no this is
what happened
after that i go to the walgreens so i'm
walking in in walgreen's the water the
water
i get wet naps right and i get um
i buy two or three extra bags jesus and
so then i take the underwear off i put
it in these two extra bags i threw it in
the trash can i wipe my [ __ ] out as
best i could i stick the pants back in
but there's still poo in my jeans i come
home and then quinda comes out and she
sees me putting the [ __ ] jeans in the
[ __ ]
oh sure it was just a bad bad morning
that was considerate of you to poo in a
bag though yeah have you ever done that
yeah i was at first no i [ __ ] on a house
with her she's he's [ __ ] on someone's
plants yeah yeah
on some like gardenias yeah yeah
yeah but it like it wasn't even
intentionally into the gardenias it just
sprayed back yeah yeah as he was bending
over it just sprayed backwards with just
that propulsion
talk about the airport what do you mean
why cancun
you know what you know what happened at
the airport no he doesn't know did you
tell him what happened to the airport i
have no i don't know what i feel like we
have to call steve lee no no no no no
can we just please call steve and see if
he picks up because i feel like his
account of the story might be the best
let's let's get his account
i'm gonna tell you my account yeah i'll
tell you my account and we can get ahold
of him look at his account everyone's
listening this is bobby's account okay
so we you know you you land and then you
get to like the
exit way and you see just a thousand
people going you need a cab you need a
cab cap you know i mean people taxi
drivers and stuff and it's pouring rain
okay
hey steve
hey you're on the podcast right now we
wanted to ask you your brother's about
to tell the story about when we first
landed in cancun
at the airport closer
and when i went outside and he went
outside and he was crossing the street i
i we wanted to hear it out of your mouth
since you saw the whole thing
oh it sounded like a fat pig hitting the
concrete
what
all right that right there all right
hang up
hang up the phone steve thank
all right
and the whole time and the whole time
steve was like you call yourself a man
yeah why fighting words yeah it popped
up like bruce lee
that's good that's good well that's
there's a compliment there thank you i
did pop up like bruce lee thank you so
much that was a fun trip it was a great
job all right get hang up the phone
thank you
thank you you [ __ ] rat [ __ ] that's uh
steve lee's account my brother just said
that i felt i felt like a fat pig on
concrete
so i'm wearing my like slippers and
and i'm walking and it's literally in
front of hundreds of like cab drivers
and tourists and people right yeah and i
slip
my stomach just hits the ground
stomach
like a puff like like it was like an
explosion yeah yeah and you could hear
people laughing yeah you know
my arm's bleeding your entourage is
laughing i could not well i ran over to
help him but at the same time i couldn't
stop like cry laughing yeah that i was
just of no use to him at all
and then i got up real quickly and i
turned around to everyone i go i'm fine
i try to make a joke out of it yeah you
have to because it's so embarrassing
you have to yeah and then my brother
goes uh you call yourself a man out loud
out loud too many times and then he's
laughing he's like you felt like a fat
pig on concrete like he said it out loud
so specific and people are just laughing
and i'm thinking to myself i go
don't rage out
everything's fine vacation is not off to
a good start yeah it's starting first
thing yeah
oh and then there was a moment where you
fought dean oliver
okay all right remember on the hill yeah
yeah
oh i know i got my ass kicked remember
yeah whoa tell the story it was just it
wasn't it was a great school there was
this kid named dean oliver and i was
friends with david david
that i played the casio with oh that's
the same guy yeah yeah his older brother
and him weren't cool but i was best
friends with david dean oliver was like
this white kid right and he was people
used to pick on him oh they called him
dean the bean yeah right that's his
fight and i would literally on the bus i
would walk up to him hey dean good
morning i would spit in his face he
wasn't jesus bobby yeah
you know what he was a he was like a
marching band kid yeah yeah you know
you're a [ __ ] bully yeah yeah i would
you put a burger right stick it on his
face okay you're both
yeah yeah so then one day dean oliver
goes
you know what man meet me after school
at the at the dirt lot right on top of
martin like a movie it was true it was
true it was promoted i don't know who
promoted it but everyone in the
neighborhood yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
on top of that
oliver right my brother's there and
everybody right yeah and dean doesn't he
you know i was kind of trying to i
didn't think he was going to fight me he
fought he [ __ ] hits me in the face i
[ __ ] you up dude and i bloodied it
yeah i'm dizzy and he beat the [ __ ] out
of me yeah
just hitting my face a couple of times
oh my god and i did some like arms in
the pants
i fell in the ground and then i i was
winded right and scared right and i
never picked time yeah again tell me
what tell them the part where mom drives
out oh yeah then mom drives up wait
papi get in the car yeah sure yeah yeah
yeah and i'm blind so my mom saved him
yeah
did you cry i kind of was
[Music]
okay i know
i know i couldn't do it but that put me
in a weird situation because i was best
friends with his younger brother i know
so david me and david were he was a kid
with the cashier yeah i was best friends
with david i know i'm so sorry that's
cool you [ __ ] deserved all that
i spit at his face oh yeah i was a
[ __ ] meanie but you know what people
bullied him who was the guy on the
wrestling team that stuck your head in
the toilet i don't want to name his name
but art kimball
i don't want to name his name here's the
full name
it's his address steve this is social
security
art kimball was
the heavyweight on for his wrestling
team he was on varsity
and he would pick on bob bob was trying
to make 105. he was cutting down from
120 trying to make 105. and he would
stick my brother's head in the toilet
for what in the locker room he was a
bully funny george
i'm worried about his health
there's so much he's going to get a
colonoscopy
there's so much meat
korean barbecue and just meat that
hasn't digested i know his body i am his
brother
he's got so much
just stored meat
yeah bulgogi and steak and because he he
eats so good
we need to get him like flushed out okay
let me tell you my point of view okay
okay
so when you told me to clean the car i
went down there all right i cleaned the
driver's seat because when i climbed
back in there was [ __ ] all over the
driver's seat yeah and when i looked
back there right
it looked like
just the
back in the day during vietnam just like
you know
you know just a war zone
there's [ __ ] all over the place and i
just thought to myself i got fifty
dollars
and she did it thank you jenna but then
here i went to the store though
that night
right and the [ __ ] was still back there
the pooh yeah and the you know we have a
lot guy at the comedy store
and he walks in the car and he goes
dude
it smells like [ __ ] in here like there
is
right
and he just left my car there the whole
night in one spot he had to maneuver all
the cars around my car they wouldn't
drive it they wouldn't drive it
yeah yeah
so if you don't want people to drive
your car that's a good way to do it you
know i mean and then also on top of it
um i'll tell you i'll tell you my point
of view on the incident okay yeah so
when i you could have went out let's
just listen listen to what i what now
can you listen to my point of view yeah
all right
so when i was at terrace which is
delicious by the way i ordered just a
chicken tingama we had super nachos no i
didn't have super nachos in a quesadilla
i ate it
and i i was i left the restaurant and
then in my head i'm like oh [ __ ]
i
she i order her a salad
right so i ran back in i had already
bought it i could you have the salad i
said to go
yeah and as soon as he grabbed i'm like
this food i got to get this to kalyala
because my little baby honey is starving
he's going to put it on me no i'm not
going to put it on your baby baby honey
but then when i was
walking out of the building this is what
i heard
right that wasn't even a fart that was
my stomach oh damn
that was your stomach yeah yeah that
wasn't even a fart
i farted inside my body
yeah
have you ever done that it just yeah
i've sucked one i've sucked whatever
yeah in my body
and a little sweat and i was just like
what do i do now this is as an adult you
have these questions
should i get in the car and just [ __ ]
drive home
right or should i just go to the
bathroom here what about going to terry
at terry yeah it was in terry still what
did you just go use her back because she
had to do her salad i would why but it
was awesome
i know i also just say can i just say
this it wasn't fully like oh i can [ __ ]
right now right i could just feel like
brewing up yeah
right for the record baby honey could
have waited i know a whole hour
i know for a salad i know okay so when
you pulled over no initially she got it
wrong
okay
so i'm not even on the freeway okay i'm
like kind of like where you know where
highland is but this is like five
o'clock it's packed it's packed
right and it won't move and all of a
sudden
i fell apart that's a fart nothing came
out just far no but it was like you know
how the that was like my opening act
like my opening act was strong
yeah
and right then i thought the middle act
was going to go up but no but the
headliner was there
you'd have time to prepare yeah yeah
there was no middle app nowhere it was a
shark no it was boop and then the head
stuck out
right like that out of the hole like
that right felt solid and i go where's
the middle act
yeah yeah i mean a couple more farts
there's no middle act right
so he needs to go up now the headliner
he needs a diarrhea
the fact that it wasn't diarrhea
means that it wasn't that urgent it was
urgent are you out of your mind it was
so urgent and let me just say this right
now did you see the back of my it was a
it was a show this show
it was a variety show oh wow not just
that right it wasn't just stand up it
was
there was water you know i mean there
was like you know i mean some other
thing that magic there's a combo magic
shirt
so i pull over to a residential area and
there's construction happening on my
right side and there's you know how
those gigantic construction um
trash containers the gigantic ones
i pull right behind there and i jump in
the back seat i pull my pants down and i
s you know all over
okay and the the beginning of it was the
solid part but the end i'm telling you
right now as jesus as my witness
it was a liquid shell
like oh like cirque du soleil yeah a
circle
okay
and i i felt like killing myself
god this smell must have been horrific
it was horrific but he still brought up
my salad with a truck full of [ __ ] in
his butt he came home and there's poo
everywhere but he had a salad at one
hand clean dedicated yeah dedicated you
haven't done that ever huh i've done it
all the time she's seen me poo on houses
yeah on house walls like he will
actually just bend over shoot it like
point his butt at a wall and spray
she saw me do that and on someone's like
gardenias yeah yeah
we need to eat as a doctor uh we gotta
help we gotta fix it maybe maybe not
i mean his health man
you know no i'm serious yeah like you're
being real serious right not being
serious so you let me ask you something
what do you think is going on with me
your diet
is all meat you think i eat all me no